allora primo teteks quando qualche mese
fa ho ricevuto l'invito ho detto adesso
cosa gli racconto potrei parlare di come
creare una strategia per alte
prestazioni potrei parlare di un altro
cavallo di battaglia che l'equilibrio
vita lavoro quindi dell'iphone family
management e poi ha detto no voglio
parlargli di qualcosa che per me ha
fatto un enorme differenza che è stato
sfidare il concetto di normalità
perché vedete quando una persona grandi
sfide quando hai grandi sogni grandi
obiettivi e spinge in maniera forte per
cercare di realizzarli
a un certo punto ti rendi conto che
guardandosi in giro ti senti un po solo
isolato fuori contesto e qualcuno ti fa
sentire anche non normale e potrebbe
capitarti che arriva anche qualche
persona e te lo dice oa le guarda che tu
non sei affatto normale e te lo dice con
quel disprezzo che ti fa male al cuore e
ti fa dubitare di te in quel momento
e allora cos'è la normalità
vedi normalità e il comportamento più
frequente che osservi nelle persone
intorno a te normalità e la spinta a
omologarsi al sistema sociale e
culturale in cui vivi normalità è
solamente un numero il numero di volte
in cui un comportamento viene ripetuto e
quante più persone ripetono quel
comportamento tanto più esso è
considerato normale ma io vi invito oggi
a ribellarvi al concetto di normalità
perché la normalità è una grande
trappola che ti fa accettare ciò che è
inaccettabile e vedi io penso che no non
c'è nulla di normale in queste cose non
c'è nulla di normale nemmeno stare in un
ascensore e tenere lo sguardo basso
perché non sai cosa dire non c'è nulla
di normale nel non dire bravo
a tuo figlio perché tuo padre non l'ha
mai detto te non c'è nulla di normale
nel tradire
perché se è stato tradito però non è
facile ribellarti alla normalità
perché se tu vuoi cambiare il mondo se
vuoi migliorarlo
inizierai a scoprire che intorno a te ci
sono tante persone che il mondo non
vogliono cambiarlo perché cambiare il
mondo significa prima di tutto cambiare
te stesso
vi racconto una piccola mia storia
ero in prima media il professore di
italiano ci dà un tema di fantasia e ci
dice di raccontare un viaggio fantastico
grande ero felicissimo perché io sono il
quarto di quattro figli il più piccolo e
mi tolgo tanti anni con le mie sorelle
per cui sono cresciuto nel giocare da
solo nella mia stanzetta ogni tanto
arriva da mio cugino quindi quella
stanza per me era il posto delle
meraviglie in cui una coperta poggiata
su due sedie diventava una grotta una
capanna e i big jim
erano i miei compagni di avventure
quindi un tema di quel tipo non faceva
altro che è poter consentirmi di
esprimere tutta la mia immaginazione
il tema più bello della mia vita ero
felicissimo e quando il professore
italiano mi riportò è il tema con i voti
io ero lì che fremevo e scoprì che per
la prima volta presi un'insufficienza il
professore mi disse che richiese fesso
rava sentiamo più bello della mia vita
perché trova in italiano va bene però
sabella è un po troppo strano non è
tanto normale questo tema
e allora il mio spirito ribelle si
richiuse in quel bambino un po
introverso e si nascose per un po di
tempo
e allora facciamo una cosa
facciamoci ispirare dai ribelli della
normalità
lasciamoci ispirare da august che
incrocia le braccia di fronte al saluto
nazista
lasciamoci ispirare da rosa che si
sedette al posto dei bianchi avviando un
grandissimo cambiamento oppure
lasciamoci ispirare da i due atleti di
colore che vinsero le olimpiadi nel 68 e
ricordarono sul podio che non c'è
differenza tra razze oppure lasciamoci
ispirare dallo sconosciuto di piazza
tienanmen che si mise lì in tutto da
solo e arrestò l'avanzata dei carrarmati
questi e personaggi ci ricordano che
anche dentro di noi c'è il seme della
ribellione verso la normalità hanno
fatto tutte cose non normali
e allora qual è la difficoltà nel
innaffiare questo seme e lasciare che
possa germogliare produrre dei frutti
il fatto che sin da piccoli siamo
cresciuti circondati dalla normalità
che ci faceva sentire sbagliati quando
seguivamo il nostro naturale modo di
essere
quando eravamo veramente noi stessi
quando come me alla scuola media
mi misi a esprimere quello che ero in un
tema
ora ci fanno sentire sbagliati
semplicemente perché diversi dagli altri
e quindi non normali il fatto è che
solamente ribellandoci alla normalità
ribellandoci a quella spinta ad
omologarsi noi riusciamo ad accedere a
un qualcosa di meraviglioso
la nostra straordinarietà sì perché e
andando oltre l'ordinario
andando oltre la normalità che entriamo
nel campo della straordinarietà e lì
dove noi possiamo reincontrare
riabbracciare rifare nostro quell'essere
piccolino che si era nascosto che non
aveva più avuto il coraggio di poter
essere se stesso perché considerato non
normale ecco il nostro vero essere la
nostra vera natura e quella che crea
valore è quella che crea amore è quella
che crea unione è quella che crea
evoluzione e soprattutto un cambiamento
nel futuro ma anche qui c'è un qualcosa
a cui dobbiamo fare attenzione perché vi
sto parlando soprattutto di una
ribellione interiore di una rivoluzione
interiore e sapete cosa accade accade
che in un mondo di uguali le eccezioni
spaventano
accade che le persone non vogliono che
tu cambi quando in realtà stai tornando
semplicemente ad essere chi sei e le
persone ostacoleranno questo cambiamento
perché quando ti incontreranno e tu
sarai di nuovo te stesso
sarai lo specchio di quello che loro non
hanno avuto il coraggio di essere di
quello che loro non hanno avuto il
coraggio di fare cambiare e ritornare ad
appropriarsi di se stessi però la verità
è che questa è l'unica strada che
abbiamo e quando tu incontrerà i queste
persone ti dovrei ricordare di questa
piccola storia c'era un gruppo di
ranocchi che nello stagno incontrando si
lanciarono una sfida vediamo chi arriva
prima sulla montagna questa sfida
diventò l'evento dello stagno e allora
tutti gli animali andarono lì per
cercare di capire
se queste erano chiede piccole piccole
fossero state in grado di arrivare in
cima
e allora partì la gara e le prime
ranocchia rotolarono giu e tu lo vedi
ma dove andate voi piccoline una
montagna così alta non ce la farete mai
e più le ranocchietta salivano e tanto
più cadevano verso il basso e da giu
ma lasciate perdere non ne vale la pena
siete troppo piccole per riuscirci
finché una sola ranocchietta riuscì
piano piano piano piano ad arrivare in
cima
e allora stupiti gli animali andare un
incontro gli chiesero come il fatto ad
arrivare fino in alto sono cadute tutte
tranne tu e la ranocchietta non
rispondeva rocchetta guardia stiamo
parlando con te ci dice qual è il
segreto e la ranocchietta non rispondeva
allora gli animali stizziti dissero ecco
non solo è arrivata fino in alto ma
adesso se la tira pure guarda quante
antipatica semplicemente quella
ranocchietta era sorta
e allora quando vi diranno di non
cambiare quando ve lo diranno nel mondo
sbagliato quando cercheranno di bloccare
il fatto di ribellarvi a una normalità
che non mi fa essere voi stessi
fate come la ranocchietta tappatevi le
orecchie e lasciate che il bruco possa
trasformarsi in farfalla ma è una
farfalla particolare perché questa
farfalla è una farfalla che accende
qualcosa di meraviglioso è una farfalla
che accende l'eccellenza perché
l'eccellenza e la chiave che apre la
porta della straordinarietà eccellenza e
fare cose ordinarie in modo
straordinario eccellenza è superare i
tuoi standard superare i tuoi limiti
superare quello che ti hanno messo in
testa essere la tua normalità eccellenza
e creare valore per te per gli altri
ogni cosa che fai anche la più piccola
come entrare in un ascensore guardare
delle persone negli occhi fare un
sorriso e salutarla invece tenere lo
sguardo basso l'eccellenza e dare la
spinta al tuo bruco per far sì che
l'essere esca fuori dal bozzolo in modo
tale che questo può essere questa tua
vera natura
questa tua essenza possa volare libera
sul mondo e lasciare una scia indelebile
di cambiamento perché vedi tu forse non
lo sai ma se qui oggi per un preciso
motivo non è casuale che tu sia qui il
tuo essere
da oggi non si sentirà più solo il tuo
essere sa che qui dentro ci sono dei
ribelli come te che casomai qualcuno è
già uscito dal concetto di
straordinarietà di ordinarietà e sta
facendo cose straordinarie
qualcuno è ancora imbrigliato e sta
lottando nel bozzolo per cercare di
trasformarsi a volare però tu qui oggi
ci sei per un preciso motivo
e questo motivo quale è che anche tu
come me come tutti gli speaker qui sul
palco come noi
sei un fallimento della normalità
sai quando esce quell'errore su windows
ecco tu sei quella finestrella e che
dice pericolo pericolo
qua c'è un fallimento in corso e ti
prego tu resta questo fallimento della
normalità perché in fondo in fondo
sai anche tu come me come noi
devi liberare il tuo essere
per poter creare veramente un
cambiamento e anche tu come me come noi
è un ruolo ben specifico che tocca solo
a te fare io non potrò mai farlo al
posto tuo ci servi tu proprio tu
e allora qui non sei per caso
perché io ti invito alla ribellione
io ti invito alla ribellione di un
qualcosa che non sei
io ti invito a ritornare straordinario
come eri bambino perché vedi tu ce l'hai
questo seme della ribellione devi fare
in modo che quel bambino ritorni fuori
ecco come adesso sono io mettici un
grande faro e farlo risplendere perché
sappi che anche tu come me come noi in
fondo sei un'anomalia del sistema
grazie
[Applauso]